con las normativas para el juicio
político las deciden ambas bancadas sin
embargo hay algunas reglas establecidas
de antemano por la constitución por
ejemplo que la destitución de un
presidente requiere de dos terceras
partes del senado así dice el artículo
1º sección tercera cláusula sexta de la
constitución el senado tendrá el poder
exclusivo para juzgar todas las
acusaciones cuando se reúnan para ese
propósito deberán estar bajo juramento o
afirmación cuando el presidente de los
eeuu sea juzgado el presidente del
tribunal supremo liderará la sesión
ninguna persona será condenada sin la
concurrencia de dos tercios de los
miembros presentes de otras votaciones
del juicio anteriores como la
constitucionalidad de la destitución o
posteriores como su inhabilidad política
y sanciones sólo necesitan mayoría
simple sin embargo la suma importancia
de destituir a un presidente obliga a
tener una mayoría más amplia que
certifique un real rechazo de la cámara
alta- el senado se divide actualmente en
48 legisladores demócratas dos
independientes cercanos a los demócratas
y 50 republicanos
destituir a donald trump se necesitan 67
votos dando por supuesto que los 50
demócratas votarán en contra del ex
presidente 17 republicanos tendrían que
sumarse a los demócratas un indicador
son los votos para la constitucionalidad
del proceso de impeachment contra trump
en el que seis republicanos se unieron
en el voto a los demócratas sin embargo
para una destitución de mantenerse estos
seis votos serían necesarios otros 11
los republicanos que votaron por la
realización del juicio político son
susan collins de maine bill cassidy de
luisiana lisa murkowski de alaska mitt
romney de yuta densas de nebraska y pat
toomey de pensilvania éstos valoraron
positivamente los argumentos de los
fiscales demócratas y consideraron que
el equipo legal de trump no realizó una
buena defensa sin embargo nada asegura
que mantengan su posición en la votación
final de misfits
[Aplausos]